c'est un samedi plutôt tranquille pour
les partis politiques fédéraux en
campagne électorale en fait seul le npd
y avait un rassemblement partisan à
saint jérôme les néo démocrates en ont
profité pour souligner bien sûr le
quatrième anniversaire de la mort de
jack layton
mais le chef thomas mulcair a surtout dû
répondre aux attaques de ses adversaires
oui il a été la cible de plusieurs
attaques aujourd'hui et pascal aussi que
le npd actuellement et est en tête selon
les derniers sondages évidemment ça le
place en position il est dans la ligne
de mire de ses adversaires et il a dû
défendre son plan pour les garderies au
secteur mulcair a annoncé un million de
places à 15 dollars cette semaine mais
les libéraux l'accusent de ne pas avoir
précisé que les provinces devraient en
payer une bonne partie 3 milliards de
dollars pour que ce plan fonctionne mais
l'attaqué la plus virulente est venue
des conservateurs qui ont publié donc
une publicité assez agressive sur les
médias sociaux où il traite carrément
d'imposteur et de ne pas avoir d'avoir
tenu là un double discours sur les
syndicats mais pour thomas mulcair
il s'agit tout simplement d'un signe que
sa campagne va bien on va l'écouter
c'est une signe de désespoir conditions
ils sortent des attaques sont devenues
comme ça les gens sont capables de les
juger eux le public jugé très très
sévèrement la personne qui se livrent à
ce genre de trucs
par contre dés semblent réticents à
endosser l'étiquette du candidat de la
gauche canadienne
oui en conférence de presse tout à
l'heure on est plusieurs journalistes à
lui avoir posé la question êtes vous
prêt à vous pro a à être le candidat de
la gauche canadienne vous prêt à
endosser cette étiquette là monsieur
mulcair qui n'a jamais voulu répondre
il préfère se qualifier du candidat
social-démocrate dans la course et il
nous a donc répondu ceci je laissais
social démocrate
travaille avec acharnement pour amener
de l'avant au niveau social
environnemental et économique des
politiques progressistes qui vont aider
les gens alors à gauche ou à droite on
peut s'attendre à ce que ses adversaires
dans les prochains jours le talonne sur
cette question là est évidemment qu'il
n'ait d'autre choix que de se prononcer
sur sa place sur l'échiquier politique
pascale au revoir